let's go back to um what's going on with
the economy one of the more popular
videos on your channel it's got it's got
almost 700 000 views on it and the title
is the global elites great reset agenda
can you talk a little bit about um
and that video is about a year old so
maybe you can kind of like update some
thoughts on that you know today on what
you think is going on with guys like
claus schwab and bill gates and the
great reset what are your thoughts on
that
well i actually just did a presentation
on this at mark moss's event in in
dallas so it's kind of fresh on my mind
and i think
you know to make a short story long here
you've got to start by going back to
1513
the year and this is when machiavelli
wrote his book called the prince
and if any of your
viewers or listeners haven't read the
book or at least watched like a
documentary you got to do it
it's called the prince the prince yeah
it's only about 90 pages
and uh
basically back then uh kind of the the
mainstream narrative if you will is that
what made a good leader or a king or
prince was integrity
was honesty
was
you know virtue all of these things and
uh machiavelli was the first one that
came out and said you got
you're lying to yourself that what the
way you stay in power
as a politician
is by doing the opposite of that if you
want to do good you've got to be willing
to be bad
ethically you got to abandon all morals
you've got to be willing to go against
your word you've got to be ruthless
you have to do these things or else
you're a not even going to get into
power and b if you get there you're not
going to keep your position of power
so uh you know fast forward
to the 1900s and several of the
dictators
were
very very influenced by machiavelli a
hitler a stalin just to name a few
john gotti used to reference the prince
all the time
and it had a massive impact on a
gentleman by the name of henry kissinger
so much so that the one of the more
recent versions of the prince is still
in print today
the cover of it has henry kissinger on
the cover
and so
now we go to 1967
and uh
klaus schwab takes a class or a seminar
from kissinger at harvard and he said
that that was one of the had one of the
greatest impacts on his life
and uh you know kissinger back then was
saying things like one of his famous
quotes like if you control the food you
control the people if you control the
energy you control countries
if you control money
you control the world
and so then you've got klaus saying that
kissinger was one of the biggest
influences on his entire life
now we go back a little bit to the 1800s
and there's another gentleman there
by the name of thomas malthus and so if
you've ever heard the term malthusian
it started with thomas malthus and he
was the first one to really articulate
this view
where if the global population
increased exponentially
that would lead to significant problems
because we live in a world of limited
resources
and so he actually argued for
uh you know controlling the birth rate
put it mildly maybe even depopulating uh
he argued why war was a good thing
because it would wipe out half the
population
and that that's better because now
we're not constrained by the or we're
not we're temporarily
dodged a bullet as far as being
constrained by the resources relative to
the population i mean these are things
that you would say out loud
and it since then it's been very popular
with the intellectual elite
right so uh you fast forward to 1968
there's a
group that was set up called the club of
rome and they're basically just taking
malthus ideas and just kind of
repackaging them for the modern age
and klaus schwab was very very moved and
influenced by the club of rome as well
to the point where in 1972 he set up the
world economic forum in 1971.
it was called something different but in
72 he had the gentleman who set up the
club of rome uh to do a speech on his uh
most recent paper called limits to
growth
and i'm sorry the paper came out in 72
he did the speech at the world economic
forum in 73. so limits to growth became
kind of a worldwide phenomenon and again
it was just regurgitating these ideas
these malthusian ideas and so much so
that
mit actually turned it into a computer
program where they projected the end of
the world
based on human population growth
uh pollution and damage to the
environment
and then in 91 the club of rome which
still exists today i came out with
another paper that was wildly popular
that kind of re-articulated their views
but then said the only solution is not
at a local level it's not at an
individual level it's not at a state
level it's not at a country level the
only way you're going to solve this is
through central planning and basically a
global government
and this echoed a lot of the thoughts
from henry kissinger as well
so then when you you fast forward to
today and uh you know i'm sure a lot of
your viewers have seen the clips of bill
gates uh talking about how there's a big
problem with the population going from 7
billion up to 9 billion or 12 billion
and this is just him looking at the club
of rome and being influenced by klaus
schwab and this is just a malthusian
idea
that he also is taken to heart and
really thinks that sure okay malthus
kind of got it wrong in the 1800s we
figured out some solutions there and
maybe the club of rome was early
but by 2050 this is definitely going to
impact the world so you know being a a
megalomaniac and these people thinking
that they are superior genetically and
intellectually to
the other seven billion people on earth
uh they figure that if the you know if
they can't solve the problem then we
can't solve the problem collectively
either the free market cannot do this
so you've got two options either you
reduce the energy use or you reduce the
birth rate or ideally you do both and
that's why
when you look at everything that's
happening in the world whether it's the
great reset agenda whether it's the
government's response to uh we'll call
it the cerveza sickness keep it youtube
friendly uh even right there trudeau you
know trudeau is just a pawn of uh of
klaus schwab i mean
and you the way you know this is because
when you hear klaus schwab speak and
hear trudeau speak he uses the exact
same words it's like it's a script that
they're given and uh
yeah exactly and biden does the exact
same thing yeah so um we go into this
world where we are today where uh you're
looking at what they're doing and i
would go so far as to say russia as well
uh you look at that and uh you look at
this push towards woke-ism
as another thing you know this is
something that i've seen very very few
people connect the dots and it's
definitely applicable to your channel
you know you talk about this all the
time but i think that
one of the reasons the global elites and
you know now they're in bed with the
corporations as well one of the reasons
why they're pushing this woke agenda so
much
is because it reduces the birth rate
and if you just look at their three main
objectives and i've kind of done a lot
of thinking on this and i think you can
really summarize it by saying uh you
know the reduction in energy like we're
saying reduction in the birth rate and
then usurping power control and wealth
so if you look at it either
softens the population and it makes it
more compliant too yes yeah and and i
think that that the their reaction to
the cerveza thing so it was a a a big
step forward for them to condition
people to basically believing in
absurdities
um and you know and you know you look at
all the absurdities throughout the
mainstream narrative right now
and the more you can get people to
believe in what is just ridiculous
the more power and control you have over
their their daily life
and uh you know even looking at what's
happening in russia ukraine you know why
is it that the media is just so
hell-bent on
the u.s getting involved with with
russia you know why isn't it something
uh
you know like afghanistan or why isn't
it something uh that where the media is
not paying as much attention to it like
they have in wars
in the past and you say oh it's about
you know putin invading a democratic
society
okay
i think if you look at the propaganda
around this and you know we see it
recently with this push towards sweden
and finland
joining nato and i think that it's
because
the global elite want the united states
to get involved because it helps them
achieve those three objectives you know
look at it through that lens is it going
look what's happening in europe right
now you know they're having to ration
natural gas they're having to ration
energy use they're having to ration
electricity okay what's objective number
one check that box okay we go to into a
nuclear war
okay check box number two decreases the
birth rate in the population that's for
sure
and then if we go into a war you know
who are the the entities that benefit
from that it would be the global elite
the politicians the people are the ones
especially the poor and middle class
that always end up paying the price so i
wouldn't go so far as to say that
they're behind everything
but the title of my presentation at
mark's event was
never let a crisis go to waste
and i think that they've got these
objectives and then when a crisis
presents itself
they sit back and say okay we influence
this politician this corporate head this
ceo you know this hedge fund manager
these people that come at to davos so
and this you know mainstream media
outlet so how can we
how can we position a narrative around
this crisis and implement policy that'll
help us achieve one two or all three of
those objectives we just outlined hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you